here in the u.s russia's actions could
also lead to even higher energy prices
for americans errol barnett is in
washington with more on that part of the
story errol good morning
hey there dana good morning look we're
all about to feel this in some way shape
or form fuel prices are creeping higher
and you have several factors at play
chief among them these newly announced
sanctions against russia but you also
have high fuel demand in europe and a
limited global supply all of that is
pushing the price for a barrel of oil
steadily toward 100 we're not there just
yet but we're getting close gas prices
are continuing their upward march with a
gallon of regular now costing you an
average of 3.53
and the cost of heating oil is also up
get this it's costing americans 47
percent more now to warm up our homes
with heating oil this winter than it did
a year ago now russia is a major
exporter of oil and natural gas selling
12 and 17 percent of the global supply
respectively so whatever the economic
punishment russia receives here in the
coming days and weeks it is likely to
put increasing pressure on the global
supply chain which we already know is
fragile now the byte administration is
trying to coordinate with some of the
world's major oil producers and
consumers to secure global energy
supplies it has not ruled out
eliminating the federal gas tax but nate
because of the size of this problem
those efforts will only have an
incremental impact
yeah we are feeling the impact of the
crisis in ukraine arrow thank you